the community is still feeling the pain
of knowing tina tintort died in a fiery
crash along with her golden retriever
max this was allegedly caused by former
raiders player henry ruggs as he was
driving under the influence and hit
tintor's car going over 100 miles an
hour but today dog lovers from all
across the valley use that pain as a way
to come together for a pack walk in
honor of them both victoria saha was
there for the event and joins us live in
studio tonight victoria
these people were all strangers to the
tintor family but each of them affected
by what happened to tina and her golden
retriever max this walk was in honor of
tina's love for dogs and let her family
know vegas is grieving with them which
her family saw for themselves
slobber and barks something tina tinter
would have loved dressed in black her
family faced the public in the midst of
their grief to honor tina her mom shares
an emotional embrace with one of the
organizers of the pack walk that was
held in honor of the two lives lost the
family was not ready to speak with me on
camera just yet but shared this video of
max as he's walking himself with his
leash in his mouth you can hear tina
praising him
oh boy
we need this we need to we didn't need
the family to know that they are not
alone that the community is here for
them as well organizer angela pincion
says they had every dog wear white
bandana symbolizing peace tina's other
dog a three-year-old husky named bella
also joined in on the walk the pack walk
brought dog lovers from all across the
valley
the thought of what happened and
i visualize it being me a scary thought
that also brought so many others wanting
to honor tina and max happened a few
miles away from my house so it really
kind of hit home
and my husband drives uber you know
around the time that it happened so i
mean it really could have been anybody
uncle says they appreciate all the
support during this painful time but
right now they have to fight for justice
for tina and max